oh we're back and nothing has changed
everything is the same you know a game
this is probably from you read the title
of the video I turn the volume down for
a second we're on the menu screen but
hey everybody evil the bonus annals
chronicles never call them that yeah
weevil seven back a few months ago yeah
now we're back we've played all of the
Resident Evil's in the numbered series I
played them typically while you would
tell me what to do because you've played
every resident evil known to man and I
didn't but now I have played one through
seven but what I haven't played is all
those all the ones in between yeah so
Code Veronica which we're gonna play
we're playing cover on tacacs the ps2
version ported over to ps4 so this is
not that HD 360 ps3 version I know
nothing about this yeah I've only ever
beaten it once so this will be
interesting this is a tough game so try
to keep you on your toes as much as
possible but other than that it's going
back to old-school Resident Evil
I'll go right over to yeah tell me about
what we're looking at here this is
Claire Redfield it's our camera ok we're
good um yeah she's doing a puzzle there
she is the 10th Veronica what this is
Claire Redfield she's going to look a
brother
yeah it's not Veronica you've Claire's
been in uh you played as Claire and uh I
can only assume it's to the tents at the
Veronica there we go uh yeah let's start
with a code to kill its gonna do it
turn it down a little bit those sick ps2
graphics I'm excited alright yeah this
is the ps2 version but like obviously
the game came out on dreamcast resident
whoo I missed that resident you know I
heard that in resonable 8 Cal come can a
patch in a version that says resident
can evil they're really catering to that
wide audience that we love so much
[ __ ] I'm missing it recapping 2 1 & 2
right
managed to escape
[Music]
it's set up three months later about
three months afterward
are you mansplaining the game number if
Rosie will seven the photo of the
helicopter is umbrella on it dude I
swear little every game ends with helis
and now they begin very long to your new
home Oh
her name is Claire Redfield we caught
her trespassing in a Paris lab facility
ten days ago she apparently infiltrated
the complex looking for her lost brother
Chris Redfield one of the surviving
members of our Phoebe's famous stars
teams
[Music]
Oh get down aah
damn she's good whoever's driving that
flying hey it's Mike who's flying that I
just wasted two of their own please he
is all this technology but he just can't
get her
she's got full movement of her torso
they're in trouble
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
they're wearing Fidel Castro hat
oh my god
catch it yes she's so cool
yeah [ __ ] yeah thought just goes around
cleaning up we have to wash for five
minutes everybody
please I have a son I am your son I'm
your son now wouldn't intro now she's
pretty badass did we play as her and two
now we did we I think did we do Krissy
it is Claire once didn't we and to it
you picked between her at Leon I'm
trying to member what we did Wow
I should notice oh right because you
were saying Claire's Leon
we were saying we would if we did play
as her we could go back and play it
again
Leon be scenario Clara be scenario yes
we never did that oh so it begins
never mind
it looks pretty good
PS like a Dreamcast game yes you it
looks great yeah the cameras moving it's
not all just still cinematography now
it's okay Azam or what's going on hi
it's she's she's not wrong okay let's
check out and see if I have any items I
have a lighter equip that [ __ ] okay well
is it not already equipped no okay did I
it was kind of like resin will remake
where it was part of your
[Music]
your party's been canceled nothing you
could easily just say something not one
word when I wasn't even one that put us
in jail I don't know I think he's been
bitten though he doesn't look good
perfect some sick lats though what does
that saying go on Plan B get out of here
laxatives this place is finished I don't
know it might have been a specialist but
in any case this prison has been taken
over like Zelda means future Katarina
what are you saying you're free to leave
the complex if you can but you may as
well know you have no chance of getting
off this island and what about you what
are you going to do don't worry about me
done I won't okay
Oh tank controls oh no like the
resonable 2/3 style can I quickly go
backwards like reverse back into circle
quick or back in ax it's back in circle
sweet that's my money
let's go pick up some stuff yeah I'll
take those handguns believe um should I
try to take these drugs how are you
feeling about getting back in the tank
controls I am NOT excited about it but I
appreciate the authenticity of what it's
doing so I'm not going to you know make
a big fuss about it but 10 controls are
obviously not here in new games for a
reason
it's authentic and it makes it reminds
me of like yeah the way it was man
here's a list of prisoners my name is at
the end I wish it said who was before it
I was a prisoner this whole time
hmm Rodrigo Juan Raval um oh no no sorry
I was trying to find I wanted her to
talk about something else
knife yeah yeah I will take that
no thank you there's something else on
the desk a box or just the lighting of
your lighter it won't look at flame it's
very large I don't know I just I don't
think so
I tried to talk to him again hey he's
bleeding
I'll need him aesthetic medicine didn't
he throw something on the ground he did
but it's empty
oh yeah all right that's all I got I
don't know what this is and it doesn't
want me to talk
people are getting hosed down in there
that's where they like water what do you
call that waterboarded people I don't
think you need a fire hose to water
boards where they did that that thing
where they have a drip on your forehead
and you slowly go insane and they
torture you that's isn't that
waterboarding almost mm no waterboarding
is when they put the tower
how are you and they like kind of drown
you waterboarding sorry the other one is
like weird they like just like tie you
to thing and they have a drip on your
forehead and can go to sleep or do
anything and just like a nuts yeah well
thanks for that you're welcome
oh they'll door animations are back oh
we really only get eight slots again I
hate this which I use it or should I
just keep going no I don't use it just
don't die also okay
I haven't gotten a gun yet is that a
thing that I should get in your
experience
eventually I don't know I should learn
how to stab okay okay yeah uh controls
hold r1 then press something X okay all
right
r1 X is how I stabbed people
it's good to know again now that we know
that they work we can proceed this sound
effects are good
this is signifying that we're going up
the stairs and trip during this
animation wow they put a lot of time to
make our laptop this is a long animation
takes a while below it's probably a big
brewery yeah that's probably why oh it's
rain that's why how you die truck used
for transport oil is leaking from the
crashed wreck a dead body and a
briefcase can be found inside I cannot
get back there booth this front-facing
camera is so rude
nothing
I will stab you maybe turn around and
run really I don't know
I wouldn't you thought fire I mean I
don't know a lot about Oh for god sakes
lady I saw you drop a gun and catch it
[Music]
what
Hickam
oh man she's not handling this well
these guys are like super naked
they're actually called naked zombies
memory serves do something good girl
dab dab crumble
well I just don't think I can take on a
hundred all right sorry that didn't go
well
all right sorry all right
oh yeah I'm a [ __ ] that gave at the
end if you can get that yeah yeah how do
I run a hold square that's why I should
have learned this hold acts without
please go through this door what was it
I got like eight bytes there that did
not go well whatever it's gotta be X or
tried now before that dude wakes up
inevitably square but
oh yeah now you're like really spry oh
[ __ ] she's good fantastic I'm coming
over okay cool
Canadian Wow turn it up
right I said I would sort my quarry I
was a prisoner on this island and I
guess you're not from umbrella you've
explosive collar
Claire Claire Redfield
I'll remember that so you thought
there's an airport around once I find I
can finally escape from this crazy
island I'll see ya okay cool yeah babe I
don't want you following me what exit is
this yeah you only slow me down
it's like Canadian Jersey I think I love
him
that guy sucks okay
Circle Circle born circle is how we do
the funky-looking pound gone
okay yeah a lot of things I don't like
the other side of that posture trainer
truck weight you have to go back for
that oh now that you have a gun you can
go back to that briefcase is that what
we're doing yes oh yeah [ __ ] shred
some zoms all right how we do oh hey
what's up remember me
come on hey what's up [ __ ]
get on the ground
see there it's twitching enemy
how do I reload you might have to go
into the menu and do the old
old-fashioned way come by them in the
menu come VIN this move finally came in
handy you're on fire stop drop and roll
loser
stop drop and die nice where is this oh
oh you think the rain would put it out
it's in the flames in the middle of them
but you didn't like when I tried to do
that
can you go between the flames up there
this is so dumb yeah no no no no no -
Joe how's my who's my help green no I'm
doing great
um maybe I need a fire extinguisher
yeah maybe okay well either way you
cleared this area out so that's good I'm
gonna touch their bodies for goodies
and other reasons goodies
did we get that guy's name
Steve weather really yeah it was yeah I
like a really shitty like this though
was a shed don't follow me lady sure I
told you I was sorry so I feel like I
could probably crawl in there but I'm
gonna investigate this area first okay
okay sure
abandoned materials are piled up here
and nothing useful
interesting
come on there Claire look together here
to defeat tank controls
like in the exterior environments so is
this a different place yeah I've never
been maybe this gets behind that nailed
or what about this this is open it it's
locked from the other side with a
padlock it can't be open oh wait can't
you get to the other side yeah but if
it's a padlock I don't have the key oh
yeah right guess so
I think all it does is open a shortcut
all right so this is a new area wait you
didn't check inside that building yet
although okay maybe you don't want to if
something I pulled in there oh no maybe
listen yeah Mary you can reset them I
mean we could go into this building just
to see I thought I remembered it
something like that happening yeah the
doors back there now you're cornered oh
wait there's an urban why can they not
get up here they can't get up there you
dumb [ __ ] you [ __ ] idiot that's
why I let this all along top of the food
chain all sudden something snatches you
choose you
[Music]
idiots do you think the dogs did it yeah
be a good tease if it wasn't them though
Ron dum-dum I backed up into him
shut up [ __ ] the camera like there's not
enough room to like just [ __ ] pop and
then wait for him to moan you shootin at
the face turn I think I see him you're
gonna I hope you like he'll stay down oh
it's the light [ __ ] yeah now wasn't just
Chumbawamba at him I wasn't great
shabby magazines have eaten food
oh it's back there I know that's trying
to get a layout there's a lot of like
corners in here you know yeah it looks
like it's useful looks like someone
didn't finish their soup it's a little
bit more that's eerie oh okay
I'm gonna wait until sorry I'm gonna
wait I'm in caution I'm gonna wait on
bring your menu up again sure what the
hell is that like goddess looking thing
oh yeah I don't
is that my special move your ultimate I
have no idea it's like the ability to
like shoot a flaming Beryl at any given
time oh sweet oh yeah
I catch guns I don't know it doesn't it
doesn't let me touch it family crest I
have no idea some came in that door
great see they go another herb good cuz
I'm not well
hmm
it'd be nice if I could get a red herb
so that I could convince okay so I
should I go in here would you let me to
go in here the little room check that
toy this toy has some more rather
disgusting stains a horrible smell it is
a toilet was this your first toilet
Claire maybe I'm sure I saw this one
dude spends a lot of his free time
documenting video game toilets Waypoint
did a story about it so he's probably
talking about the polka Monica thought
well it's disgusting and Philip stains
this lock behind you oh no everyone some
troubles brewing Lord
did Dyer this room stinks
Johnny called me a nincompoop
I hate him based on the information I
believe that I'm far south of the
Equator Bob the bunk below is one of the
interesting types of guys Bob told some
crazy story of why he was put this place
with me that that's missing a word whose
boss named Alfred he used to be an
attendant supposedly placed him in here
because of a tiny little mistake Alfred
it's not about Albert without warning a
group of military men took Bob to the
guillotine or I mean guillotine they
have a guillotine on this island
there are some really large plastic bags
constantly being removed Bob did I
shouldn't have gone there what is going
on all I could hear was some insanely
creepy laughter and the sound of Bob
screaming this is my last entry I know
that I'm next
I'm Alfred's guinea pig well he had a
rough day I hope he doesn't crash
through that window he's got double
Newsies
dodj wow that's [ __ ]
I can't see
based on the music yeah I'm still in
caution I'm okay
my shoulders hurts though oh is that
what oh it's because it takes up takes
up two slots well I could eat it herb
sure oh actually go up to that go up
twice that has the same emblem on it
what that notebook can I use this for
notebook my dumb when you obtain a new
item always remember to check it with
the check command in the status screen
remember it's always best to rotate the
item if you face an object and then
press and hold up sometimes you'll be
able to push it you can turn 180 degrees
oh this is the manual yeah when you are
lost or unsure of what to do you can
check the map screen you can get out of
here
I just curious why that oh no it's gone
damn okay well you was put to good use
anyway so now you can get does I will
get those I will take those weird guns
Luke I'm just gonna put on your shirt -
it's everywhere oh hey what's round the
corner Becca I was just checking their
box oh sorry I want to see how many
bullets I have left their toiletries
this is so rude this camera angle
oh well it's it looks like that shower
was raining blood okay well I don't have
any items to progress but at least I'm
getting bullets and guns yeah you can go
kill those other guys in the next I'm
gonna kill me some dogs oh yeah I forgot
about that
call me United what United like killed
like five dogs this week United did what
what what happened
United's bunch of idiots and killed dogs
I don't fly United anymore but how'd
they kill dogs put it in the storage
compartment instead of in the upper part
no the upper part if a little part where
you put your bag when you're sitting why
didn't people stop them hivemind maybe
you know like authority said something
then I think should I put my dog up
there I'd [ __ ] that's what I said I
was like I would kill someone if a
suffocate yeah I was very upset my dog
is fine but that was my joke
can I kill these dogs I feel much more
uncomfortable about this now
I know you get my joke though I get it
now yeah they hate I don't think you're
gonna hit them like that I don't think
this games that intuitive it's really
maybe it is I don't know Sparky
I think they're caught on the deck
always right there god damn it
die
I don't enjoy shooting you is it faster
than me yep
but it's stupider - hmm hot okay oh you
went inside well I hope that didn't
reset the damage done to him I didn't
shoot him that was the same one he went
under the Dagon came out oh god damn it
is there like a hundred of these is he
like permit
this is awful
God died that one sounded worse yeah
please
I feel awful was that a different one
maybe you're right okay we probably
could yeah dodge them and said well here
we are so see if you see if you can do
anything with that now now you can knife
it maybe okay that's a better idea
we should have died the dogs now I'm
looking back but we're fine listen if
you're gonna know every fine Oh keep
going keep going keep going
I mean it's nice essentially you open it
it just seems it's a shortcut okay how
satisfied are you very unsatisfied
all right I don't think that's gonna
work um you go back the other way
through that father there's other doors
in here right like there's this thing
yeah we need some sort of emblem a hawk
of course all right what did I miss
number that you walked into that one
outside yard with dudes in it yeah what
was that you tried dodging him where was
that behind past that padlocked door
around the building that's a dead dog
bone
all Juke dogs from now on it's also how
I just like believe I should live
because I don't feel good about shooting
dogs yeah I don't like it should I get
that
Ozzy's out because I don't have enough
bullets or should I say try dodging if
you can I guess dodge oh there's one to
buy those in yeah get in get in all
right
that didn't go great save bullets
please deposit any metallic items you
have in the security box No
guess you gotta die
is the knife metal zoom so let's find
out
we yeah push it okay so the moans are
coming from outside the building that's
good pretty sure the knife is gonna set
it off are you sure okay
it was worth testing this is an
interesting thing interesting mechanic
what about these things all right oh
right right oh your belt Oh what about
my lighter oh it's probably lighter
stupid they're gonna come through these
[ __ ] windows we all know this
no wait what's this
oh so you can grab him now I think right
no they weren't in there maybe I thought
it transferred them okay so I haven't
been in there let's check out this room
grenades
sweet sweet flame rounds oh those are
more flame rounds should I take these
some point I'm gonna run out of space
here maybe leave those there for now
probably come back through here do you
think well I mean cuz my concern what's
the left that first day it's gray
yes oh it is
that's like a diary 3d duplicator are
you new product the 3d duplicator
consists of two parts
this portion scans a 3d object simply
place the material you want to have
scanned onto the tray and the scanner as
scanned objects will be processed will
should be transferred to the duplicator
if you have the material you wish to
have converted in the machine you can
begin conversion based on the 3d data
that was created by the 3d scanner
conversion will be executed with a
complete data accuracy the result will
be an original precisely to the original
okay so scan first yeah but what do you
want to scan me speaking gimli anger
unless Claire's push the switch
[Music]
enhance
what should we scan
no you probably have to bring up your
inventory okay no no that's okay shake
it off I see now that I was dumb I
wanted to make more of them oh that's
okay no no no I don't think you could
have made it first date but well now I
have no fun nothing yet
this is the worst day of my life maybe
you don't use that yet oh my god I can't
believe I did that as soon as I hit it I
was like wait that's a bad idea
someone's typing in here yeah that's
weird
hey it's me Steve um prison guard man
Carl Grisham new product sample from
metal industries tg01 it'll be in the
metal briefcase so the thing in the
briefcase is tg01 oh my god it is Steve
field what are you doing here I told you
not to follow me
this red field is he a relative of yours
or something you mean my brother ah your
siblings good one well it seems your
brother's under surveillance by umbrella
what what that's crazy
he's under an umbrella
and tell him to let my brother know he's
being monitored it's raining it's a good
thing I have access to an outside
connection from here
well that file shows the latitude and
longitude of this place why don't you
send your brother the coordinates and
asked him to come help thanks I'll do
that hey I was just kidding good joke
[ __ ] oh there's no way you could get
here even if he is your brother yes you
can I'm sure of it
no way
he won't come disappointed if you rely
on others who hurt you
who hurt you I want to be alone I hate
my dad you could save I think I should
considering oh no I can't I don't think
you needed to put your anger that way oh
there you go get out please no okay so
here's the how are you gonna get back
through the metal detector with that
emblem I wonder maybe that has to do
with the 3d printer thing I think I have
to go all the way around but maybe yes
what's this thing no that's a hole I go
back a lock release device okay okay
it's probably good you know the box
it's what good luck did that release no
it's probably fine
it's like not letting me please set the
material to be scanned like what does
that mean go in front of the lid again
try it with the emblem I don't know why
they would help what do you mean with
the emblem just like turn around bring
up your inventory go to the emblem [ __ ]
god I'm sure that would not have worked
with every item damn it so will it be
plastic so you can actually bring it is
my question is it still gonna be metal
[Music]
maybe I'll tell you in the description
I just click on the buttons I would say
what buy the machine again this button
it's been prepared if the materials are
said I can restore the object
I have no idea what I'm doing the
materials that go back to it go let
click on the bottom part of it the
bottom part of would like the lid go
back to the lid okay
I'm the materials set maybe there's
something you didn't find the Lord
should I get those not yet you're not
too far off the beaten path you come
back for my checked security room again
so it seems like you nits got the dead I
just need the material so I wonder what
that would be
oh there's an ink ribbon right next to
the typewriter oh for [ __ ] sakes
should I'm gonna save ya yeah three of
them oh yeah do we have memory card
we're playing this on a Playstation 4
are you sure
so my question yeah dude remember to do
separate ones in case if we need to
start over
Oh Lord it'll be okay that's part of
playing this game yeah yeah doing it
again and again you check the computer
right let me check in again yeah our Yoo
Lian as much else you could do right now
dear Leon I'm dying in the briefcase @
TG 0 0 1 maybe there's something in
there you can do yeah but it's on fire I
need prongs I have no [ __ ] like it
makes sense
oh yeah you just need the material so
what are those
so these yeah probably somewhere else
it's got to be like not metal though is
it this wood so I need materials you're
open you're very quick ok wait sorry
here we go yeah I think you just need to
find something somewhere else
in the security box I don't think the
accreditor guess they are male oh maybe
the grenades are that makes sense
please deposit any metallic items you
have in the security box pink ribbons
really this game maybe you could take
the maybe this means you could take the
grenades I'm not gonna play this game
anymore
god bless [ __ ] off
oh well on the bright side once you move
that box you can go through there
without using the middle of the sector
right but you're gonna have to fight
those arms I think yeah no I hate this
game weird-looking guns keep that ink
ribbon in there for now if you can
you're essentially can use this as an
item box you might as well okay in fact
you could I'm just worried I'm gonna
leave stuff in it I'll remember you
don't remember how do I hold my
inventory again okay so you saved so
it's used too much ammo here whatever we
can go back but do I do something am i
killing these people earn well press
that button if you can get there okay
there's gonna be dudes on the other side
I'm fairly certain
oh okay go reset yeah yeah so what does
that do I wonder I don't know something
behind that that was a lot of dudes I
need to use my uz what do you think go
go out one more time to see what their
alignments gonna be then see if you need
to use it because I usually might not be
you I think you're more likely to find
the handgun rounds thoughts
so try dodging you saved and you can go
back if you need to
well I'm definitely a real dodge 20 of
them you me go in that room cuz they're
in that room you know they're in that
room yeah try it just get out here and
see what you can do remember you can
escape to the other side that you've
waited to fire extinguisher for the free
case ok sweet there's like two of them
now
ladies yeah I would just get the reset
what do you mean I go through that door
nice to reset where they were I feel
like you could dodge them I know they're
a lot come on they're a lot more you can
kill him kill kill maybe you like
thinning out a little bit kill one and
then you still in green yeah everybody
quit it's always like the gamble of
bullets over health kill him I just
think you're more likely to find more
handgun rounds so he's dead the blood
you go away yes so kill him why I can
dodge him right but oh nice yeah there
you go get that you might have to do
some shooting on my way that's fine
hopefully it doesn't take out more than
once I'll probably take two spaces good
but two guns no honey that's a new
spaces use your handgun on them for now
sorry I was loud that was an eyewitness
so far totally on purpose
oh wait god that was so cool I went the
wrong way doesn't matter you reset them
you could dodge now you're right I
didn't know that that's what that did
it's your Claire Redfield listen I see
don't grip power yeah you could die okay
well it'll do the thing ya go this yeah
oh wait who this guy coming in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] gay [ __ ] just reset if you go fat
what I thought
fine you might as well just go now yeah
oh [ __ ] no wait go back
there's got to be something in that all
right no okay
yeah get out of here you might as well
kill him now
oh the guillotine okie sweet okay so
that's a shortcut I don't know why you
would need it yeah okay I'm never going
back in there again I understand your
plight but agree to disagree so you got
key for the padlock you might as well
use that to get out of here inventory
and open up that shortcut damn I wish we
didn't shoot all those dogs listen let's
not get hung up on how many dogs I
killed I don't want to live like this
[ __ ] use that spray so early
yeah go unlock the door so presumably
there's some sort of material maybe you
can use the briefcase convert that into
an aplastic Emblem that you can bring
with you that make any sense at all I
mean it's Resident Evil so [ __ ] I don't
remember a lot of us I'm having fun and
trying to figure this out okay so what
am i doing now I'm going to use the fire
extinguisher and get the thingy but I
don't know what to do with that that
might be the material well there's
something inside it just remember to
check it when you get it what's that
noise well you're new oh he's eating
someone right there no you have to go
that way yeah just avoid him
didn't look like you were pointing at
the door when you open I didn't feel
like it but it was my only option
you know what's gonna suck if I kill
these guys maybe they came back it is a
graveyard and random graveyard in the
middle of the prison wait no don't
why waste that if you can help it well I
I don't know how many there are and I
mean there you go oh [ __ ] yeah you meant
that equipment oh it's so yeah sure okay
use I'm gonna [ __ ] get injured here
yeah check it press that red button on a
I'm assuming there's something useful
inside or like the briefcase itself is
the material metal yeah that doesn't
make sense there's gotta be something I
mean that's clearly a red Bhutan yes
there's a button SiC tg01
I'm assuming that's like a plastic yeah
special alloy sweet okay so here's my
here's what I propose
we get back to 3d printer thing
duplicator go back go back go back this
is important
go back can't be detected by meld yeah
sweet cannot be pictured okay that's
gonna come to playable lightweight yet
durable fashionable sleep for the modern
woman on the go it sucks that you need
to make that crest because you could
probably make like a [ __ ] 3d handgun
well are you telling me that there's so
no I have to get out of here okay wait
hon here's my we can you can go make the
emblem and then we can coming up on the
end of an episode if we're doing an hour
you can go make the emblem and then save
over that way with the ribbons that you
deposited there or you can use the
emblem and see where it takes us that's
like out of the prison pretty much right
but if that's the next area might be a
little bit before a safe thing comes up
yeah I don't care we can no dad how do I
move the boxes I don't know that might
be that might be on the other side of
the emblem game all right oh yeah every
set maybe you could just dodge him oh
[ __ ] okay that's a door actually use
[ __ ] stairs again
oh I forgot they're so long oh no it's
faster going down that's the thing about
stairs yes that was faster
took like ten years so maybe you could
dodge these dicks
probably not but I'm gonna do my best at
you Tamara read that might happen yeah
just go there's one more yeah yeah get
behind him he's gonna launder out of you
I'm not doing so hot over a cover
cuz there's there's dudes here remember
just keep hugging just go straight
sprint straight right now you know me
I'm a hugger oh you're fine
ah you got a lot of space to work with
give him that juice hey boys what are
the odds those dudes all come through
the windows when you try how can you
know it that's the door either
how am i doing not great
[ __ ] did I leave guys in every room
honestly there's so many I should you
know I didn't kill the guy and the thing
you told me to and I was like shut up
now look at me you know what you can
have this [ __ ]
passive run weight lighter oh right
[ __ ] fighters
please deposit any metallic idea in the
security box virgin stupid lady
so okay
looking at the screen over here making
sure everything is up to snuff uh-huh
sweet duplication complete you now have
a clone her name is Jill
Eric Claire just gonna noted I'll go to
the right what are you doing this way
yes oh [ __ ] I don't I can't leave yeah
you're gonna have to dodge them I guess
yeah what this unlock I wonder oh you
know what this made it might have
unlocked that button outside the one
that you opened the shutter with so
there so there okay just I'd save at the
typewriter okay well you have any
ribbons
I don't yeah yeah there oh they're in
the metal thing out in the next room
just do it fast
so you're telling me did ya get that
ribbon cuz I could run through I just
get the ribbon all right good save here
oops
yeah I shoulda saved earlier yeah I got
too excited the fact that I have
numbered ribbons are like such a I've
had the luxury of being able to save as
much as I wanted in re 7 mm-hmm
this is a different ballgame I'm gonna
do a different save and then we're gonna
run for our buns ready
please deposit any metallic items yeah
you you said you know how do you know
yeah I have one [ __ ] ribbon stupid
Oh what do they expect you damn it I
really thought I had that one okay I got
one
I'm not doing great
what should i do should I take all this
stuff like do I need that leave the fire
extinguisher for now okay watch your
probably gonna need it but I would I
would say it's empty
is it yeah it says it says it yeah what
about the ink ribbon I'm gonna leave it
yeah I think next time you find a
typewriter
there will be an ink ribbon next to it
norm oh [ __ ] there's dudes out here
where am I going
oh you check your health I'm not it's
not great you might just need to use
that or dodge as much as you can
yeah I was really I gotta both really
excited about that I'm probably on
danger I think no anyway
it's being kind there's a lot of dudes
all right so here and then I'm putting
the thing in the thing yeah so many
dudes balls there's one right where I
need the thing no I suck you might as
well go for the door now dodge them and
then get to the main door wait where's
the main door toward the camera what or
just Risa nice good yeah I [ __ ] got
hurt because I went to the wrong door
you're doing well for not having used
tank controls I don't know I don't know
not having used tank jokes I don't feel
great
Oh is the Box gonna be here maybe what
box that you can move Oh that'd be cool
no wait hold on go back to this doesn't
like I can open it
alright alright alright
Oh bullies I don't know yeah oh yeah um
I'm not gonna take both of them but I am
oh we saw this turn the demo he did
sweet handgun rounds I would put those
in your handgun right now just so you
don't okay forget to reload later you've
been known to do that
excuse me well I [ __ ] know
I'm been beautiful hey you oughta foul I
should know what I'm doing yeah so
judging by like game design general
maybe they're teaching how to do this
now because you're about to push the box
from away from the door after this that
would be awesome
I mean not that would be good because
then you add the shortcut to the
typewriter yeah this is like dummy proof
see how it hits that other box there's
no way I could accidentally push it too
far
mm-hmm like they made the first one leg
for us listen here
you're not smart and I don't know how
dummy proof it is shut up I think it
goes without saying but yeah just stay
on the metal boxes jump up there stop
with Bear Singh mate jump down oh my god
I thought you're gonna get burned
oh never get up there lady step step
step
no balls up but that draw distance maybe
you do where am i okay
yeah I'd use one okay oh that's fine
it's doable level you [ __ ] owe it
dodge like yeah oh it's down the ground
are you [ __ ] you know I'm gonna die
yeah yeah
now what it wasn't great
okay octagon will Hollow there's a map
there in a palace I'm not doing so hot
there's a lot of [ __ ] dogs so back
where the dogs were yeah there was there
were stairs and go up into the palace I
don't know if you can go into the palace
yet but you can try well there's a lot
of dogs so I don't really want to like
might have to kill him I don't know who
knows there's a lot of dogs dude no ball
you got it where am I going keep moving
yeah see that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't think they come up here
hopefully please don't be like okay dog
good thing about dogs they they don't
have to just weird of stairs well yeah
they have to do more than just touch you
to grab you like I'm like new zones what
is that it's gotta be a safe room right
around here
don't hang around still sweet
Oh God I don't do you have it no I don't
think you have it your prisoner ID was
like wkd something but now now I don't
have to find someone ID
I was soon to have all their dogs we
don't have any ID number what about
backspace psy okay yeah get on this fine
I'll be funny if it sent out attack dogs
could you put in the wrong password and
what if the both these doors are gonna
be locked I mean it would make sense
right like all right save save room save
room maybe I'll pull your letter out
okay I remember this okay any time there
are bats in this game the put to you
later and it will attack you oh I don't
want to spoil too much but that's just
we'll help you yeah it's getting pretty
hurt [ __ ] off oh yeah mama she wants
that and I will not waste this one can
you inspect that yeah can you use that
as a 3d printer stuff
it's got a key lock pick that sucks like
I really am fully out of stuff I'm sure
you can't go in those stalls okay about
that broken stalled you try that no
that's right oh good okay
this toilet is filthy maybe the other
room that will be great with a box like
I haven't gotten a box yet I got all
these items I think right now yeah the
only thing is you using maybe upstairs
no things you can use it a box are those
metal detector things we don't have to
go back down there I'll go upstairs
first oh I thought I was going upstairs
I'm obviously very confused
[Music]
come on little lady I remember you've
your lighter out right now that's okay
laters are ya
hey where is my box sweet
oh wait hunt gather all this stuff first
I might be full on handgun it's 45 MX no
okay wait before you I'm just gonna put
some stuff away like these and PE the
dural m'kay so it's a duralumon it's
pronounced aluminum how's that red
notebook say dear diary
oh there sir Alfred
he's entrusted anyone he's a cray cray
man they say he lives in his twin sister
Alexia his private house on the hill
[Music]
but rather at the Duras thing about all
all right so that dudes a nut up there
nutcase ooh there's something under that
cabin right there looks like an employee
ID oh my god
maybe it's Robert Dawson's can you put
your Newsies in there oh they're not
shaped like that yeah youse gotta use
and like I eat them and I can't get them
back
I wonder if I have to push it
there you go sweet so that's the next
thing to do I guess
James after James aster NTC 0:39 for
that's my phone number okay sweet well I
just need to get some ink ribs
yeah I probably save instead of in the
box so that can jog remember you next
time with the items you have that sounds
good
there's a productive episode it was yeah
it was good for uh not having done tank
controls oh are you excited back mm-hmm
are you yes
I've missed this I was waiting for a
good opportunity I worked like three
weekends in a row you've been super busy
and I think we were just like looking
for the right opportunity to get back
yeah but you know the game being on sale
really pushed it forward
yeah she is half off yeah so we'll see
if we screwed ourselves over I think
we're doing both fine you got a lot of
stuff I have no idea but I feel
confident and we can figure it out yeah
we've ham-fisted our way through seven
other games we can do it for this one
yeah sweet we'll be back hopefully next
week yeah that's the plan
we'll be back weekly again as usual this
will be up Saturday that sounds great I
bet you there's gonna be a lot of people
wondering why James spot is playing
Resident Evil Code Veronica
what do you mean like it's a good game
no I know but when we were playing like
seven people who were wondering like oh
you're super late to the party but they
don't they don't they don't understand
the resident can evil life yeah this is
we do things the way we feel anyway when
the time is right
sweet well it's good to be back a missed
year thanks for watching everybody we'll
be back next week as always know make it
as long as there's no dogs no more dogs